donné dès minuit
ce
j'habite depuis presque trente ans en
bord de loire en tout cas tout proche de
la loire
c'est vraiment quelque chose de délibéré
c'est pas du tout un hasard
la loire est vraiment là ma source
d'inspiration au niveau des paysages
depuis toujours
et puis c'est quand même le l'endroit le
plus sauvage qu'on peut avoir à portée
de la main
je passe ma vie de peintre à courir
après des ressentis d'enfants seraient
des émotions qu'on a perdu et qu'on
essaye de retrouver genevois c'est un
des plus bel ambassadeur de la loire je
crois qu'on ait jamais eu
[Musique]
il est capable il est capable de passer
une demi-heure de 15 pages sur sa
rencontre avec un écureuil et moi je
suis capable
ces quinze jours devant un arbre devant
un peuplier devant une gloire qui coule
noire d'été en loire d'automne ou
d'hiver face et je crois que il ya
beaucoup de beaucoup de points communs
mais je comprends bien ce compromis à
celle de loi je comprends bien sans
c'est toutes ces éloges qu'il a pu faire
autour du fleuve ses reflets d'argent
c'est je ressens la loire vraiment d'une
façon très très très similaire à une
seule voie
[Musique]
le chat c'est là l'ambiance de la loire
qui est toujours qu'on retrouve à chaque
tableau est bien sûr un fil conducteur
en fait un an
on peut la retrouver également
évidemment un flux de lumière d'automne
avec de la brume comme évidemment après
la loire peut être aussi le théâtre
d'autres choses qui peuvent se passer à
notre notre époque
aujourd'hui la loire est aussi un fleuve
nucléarisé quoi tous les artistes
devraient justement ne pas se limiter à
des artistes mais a profité de la
tribune qu'on leur donne deux pour
lancer des cris pour mettre le doigt où
ça fait mal pas forcément que des
dangers mais aussi de conserver plein de
choses de protéger plein de choses
[Musique]
nous sommes à gien face à la loi j ai
une ville ligérienne elle doit tout au
fleuve
elle s'est développée principalement
c'est depuis d époque très ancienne a
s'est implanté ici et vous voyez le pont
d'ailleurs qui est à pons anciens ce
pont date de l'époque d'anne de beaujeu
à la fin du xvème siècle cette loi on
lui doit tout notamment au niveau des
transports
parce qu'à l'époque on avait pas de
chemin de fer évidemment les routes
était en très mauvais état et les tous
les bois qui étaient transportés du
berry de la sologne aboutissait à gien
une grande partie aboutisse et à gien le
port était d'ailleurs en phase sur
l'autre rive et ce port a subi les
effets des grandes crues du milieu du
19e siècle
1846 et notamment 1856 après 1856 on a
décidé de le réaliser de réaliser un
nouveau port mais cette fois ci en rive
droite
[Musique]
eh bien nous sommes maintenant à port au
bois ce fut le dernier port de gien mais
ce port va connaître une vie très courte
parce que le train fait son arrivée à
gien en septembre 1860 et 1
on va construire la ligne paris clermont
ferrand et une petite ligne une petite
ligne de 23 km dont on aperçoit la
passerelle si vous voulez qu'ils se
trouvent sur la loire
le viaduc lui-même mesure plus de 1800
mètres pour mémoire le viaduc de millau
ses 2400 mètres c'est tout simplement un
viaduc qui a été construite à la suite
de la guerre de 1870
c'est qu'il a rejoint chien qu'on a aux
morts à la petite commune d'argent au
sud donc pour pouvait avoir la
mobilisation une extrêmement rapide des
gens du massif central des gens du sud
de la france vers la région parisienne
et ensuite c'est ce qui s'est produit en
14 avec les changements on les a dirigés
vers l'est après la seconde guerre
mondiale le train évidemment a péréclité
on est resté au service marchandises
pour les lignes secondaires
et puis elles ont fermé petit à petit
définitivement
aujourd'hui la seule ligne qui
fonctionne c'est parisien clermont
ferrand
[Musique]
nous sommes ici à ceinture sur loire à
lécluse de montaut précisément qui est
un spot de pêche réputé depuis très
longtemps notamment pour ces carnassiers
historiquement le sandre et le brochet
qui étaient les espèces emblématiques de
la loire et depuis quelques années
beaucoup de silures également est un
nouvel arrivant qui hélas un poisson qui
vient aussi du bassin du danube et qui
fait la joie des pêcheurs de carnassiers
alors la loire est un fleuve un des
derniers fleuves sauvages d'europe qui
héberge une cinquantaine d'espèces de
poissons notamment des grands migrateurs
saumon à l'eau etc et qui est gérée par
les fédérations de pêche
c'est un écosystème particulièrement
riche mais également très fragile qui
est marqué depuis une trentaine d'années
par le réchauffement climatique
on a perdu 30 % du débit estivale en 20
ans et pris 3 degrés température
estivale moyenne ce qui est énorme point
un fleuve de ce type est globalement on
peut dire que d'après les suivis de la
fédération le cheptel piscicole se
maintient relativement bien mais on a
vraiment cette menace de préserver je
dirais un état écologique satisfaisant
avec un enjeu majeur qui est la lutte
contre le changement climatique
bon le spot a l'air d'être vide ce qui
est pas surprenant vu le niveau de la
loire
donc on allait tenter notre chance dans
l'état nos voisins
[Musique]
nous venons de quitter la loire et nous
arrivons sur lancers regain du canal
latéral à la loire qui permettait aux
bateaux de navigation de traverser le
fleuve à châtillon sur loire jusqu'à la
construction du pont canal de briare qui
a de fait mis heures en navigation tout
ce tronçon de kano alors on a la chance
en pays viennois au delà de la loire qui
est vraiment le territoire principal de
jeu des pêcheurs d'avoir un réseau de
canaux très dense qui est alimenté en
plus par des réservoirs notamment puisé
et en sologne et qui offre des
territoires de pêche magnifique
également d une touche et donc j'ai un
poisson n'ont plus perdu
aujourd'hui on est à peu près à 600
cartes de pêche ce qui est significatif
points qui village de 2000 habitants et
les sociétés pêche du pays viennois se
sont regroupés pour mettre en valeur ce
patrimoine à travers le tourisme et
surtout pour initier les jeunes
puisqu'on a un enjeu de recrutement de
renouvellement de générations dans la
pêche pêcheurs débutants familles en
visite sur notre territoire ou pêcheurs
spécialiste des pêches moderne
vous l'avez compris le psg doit il
paradis de la pêche nous vous attendrons
avec impatience
[Musique]
je suis artisan pastier et pour arriver
à ce paquet de pâtes
tout commence ici avec la production de
ce blé dur qui est une variété ancienne
que le produit julien de cléda un ami
paysans meunier sur votre île chatel
[Musique]
tu prépares fois comme tareen
mon tableau
[Musique]
m
du coup c'est cette variété lac est
riche en protéines
oui alors ça fait pas beaucoup de
rendement par rapport à des blés moderne
mais par contre en terme de goût pas
c'est autre chose ça se retrouve ok bon
ben il va nous servir à faire les pattes
maintenant alors j'utilise la farine
qu'on a été chercher chez vient juste
avant le blé poulard une variétés
anciennes de blé dur qu'on va
transformer en panne sèche en utilisant
la forme gigli ce qui nous semble
étrange
[Musique]
alors j'utilise des moules en bronze qui
permettent d'avoir une patte rugueuse
qui va retenir la sauce donc voilà la
forme des gigli
[Musique]
alors c'est justement la rencontre avec
julien de cléda qui est sur la même
commune de mont que moi qui a permis de
faire de développer ce projet là puisque
du coup on retrouve un projet qui a du
sens avec une production locale avec des
bons produits avec des produits qui ont
du goût et une commercialisation
derrière qui est local donc ce
partenariat s'il n'y avait pas eu ce
partenariat il y aurait pas eu la
création aujourd'hui
de ce produit de ces pâtes au blé poule
à
[Musique]
bon
on est sur une patte du coup sur lequel
on retrouve le goût de la céréale
vraiment donc en préconisations de
consommation je vous préconise de
l'associer avec une petite touche de sel
une petite touche de poivre une note
l'huile d'olive et puis un peu de marbre
parmesan dessus et puis je vous laisse
déguster et retrouver le goût de la
serial dans ses pattes
[Musique]